[Applause]
[Music]
it's eight o'clock in the morning here
in san francisco
everyone says the best way to get
started here is to come to washington
square
and take part in the tai chi
i think what we have here is the
original cast of chorus line
they like to get together run through
the old numbers
just for old time's sake one
singular sensation every little step
sheet page
yeah this is a scene that was edited out
of pirates of the caribbean
uh because this one sword fight alone i
think
lasted nine hours
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful view up here on telegraph hill
this is coit tower
i thought i'd run up inside because uh
quite frankly
it looks like a penis
all right ladies and gentlemen if you'd
like the quick tour of coit towers about
to begin
coy tower was built in 1931. that's
right
by the coit brothers uh corcoran and
corki coit
you can see a panoramic view of the area
from coit tower
if you look out there that's the pacific
ocean uh
areas of the indian ocean are over in
this section small portions of
cincinnati can be seen through that
window
the guardrail here which prevents people
from falling that was put in about two
years ago
after hundreds and hundreds of people
fell down the steps over the years
the tower stands over 666
feet tall quite brothers tribute to the
devil
alcatraz of course is right over here
behind us alcatraz uh
housed many famous criminals bugsy
siegel
the birdman of alcatraz uh the rat man
of alcatraz
little known uh eight rats uh
uh jack cheddar cheese watson who was
jailed for stealing cheddar cheese
later released uh when he promised not
to do that again then retailed for
stealing swiss cheese his name was then
changed to jack's swiss cheese johnson
little i've said makes sense
uh i apologize for that i can't believe
you sat and listened
to most of this san francisco is known
for its medical marijuana centers
this one right here but the divinity
tree
and uh thought i'd just stop in really
quickly good thing for me i brought my
uh
glaucoma glasses
acting up hello hi how are you hey how's
it going
good uh glaucoma kicking in a little bit
wondering i don't have a card or
anything but i thought maybe stop in and
get well well yeah i mean i get well i
don't know
just the eyes are clouding up a bit
when you think you see that now it
doesn't look so good does it hold up
some fingers
how many how many how many i got right
here that's a broom
your trip to san francisco is cliched
without a visit to
chinatown this is the chinatown gate
right here it's majestic
you can see the motto hanging right
below which reads restrooms for
customers only
this is cynthia yee cynthia is a
historian
of chinatown and i can only imagine
there must be a lot of excitement
that uh conan o'brien and late night
with conor o'brien coming to uh to san
francisco
oh definitely everyone is talking about
it already over tea and cakes
and we're really excited could you ask
him please are you very excited that
conan o'brien has come to san francisco
nicotine
he doesn't understand too much so he
doesn't know how to respond
back to me in english all i heard was no
i heard no
but what did you get from her body
language i enjoy him he's funny
he's i think she recognized you right
away and then she started running away
she said she has to go fix her teeth
right now in a hurry
but she's a fan and she's excited um
yes
[Laughter]
i'm coming to san francisco you you're
you're excited about the show
yeah yeah yeah yeah are you gonna watch
the show yeah it wasn't so
yeah is he lying to me or is he telling
the truth you think he's telling the
truth right
oh i think so
of course there are a lot of things to
see in san francisco a lot of famous
landmarks
but there's one that's more important
than all the others
i'm talking of course about the house
from full house
so uh let's check it out
hey hey
wow cool so uh you lived here
oh yeah oh yeah i um i never left
showing off the air i just
stayed really yeah whole cast is inside
guys conan's here
hey look it's the olsen twins hi go to
bed girls
do you want to uh go look around san
francisco with me yeah yeah i'd love to
let's go all right i'll just leave this
[Music]
[Applause]
open
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what else is there to see in san
francisco bob there's so much here conan
there's the exploratorium there's a
japanese tea garden there's
the palace of fine arts there's the
young museum there's the opera house
there's the symphony
and then then there's this place the
mitchell brothers live sex theater
[Applause]
you think this is the best way for bob
saget and conan o'brien to experience
san francisco oh most definitely really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that was great thank you wow that
was a lot of fun
we should probably uh return this thing
take it back to where we got it but that
would uh
that would take a lot of time
you